i'm sorry for a little bit after hearing
that because now she's going to a dating
coach when she should coach herself like
as a you know get experience why would
you date i'm sorry for someone who put
their themselves in there i said a
little bit because i feel like she's
she's
actually i don't know she also had a
cheek to say um
[Music]
i'm not that interested in jewelry even
after she required 200k she was like
yeah but you know that's it right i'll
be made yeah
i would hope i would hope that you don't
require anything like no presents for
ever 200k oh my god
i think like because i did say that i
feel sorry for her so i think i'll
answer that question from my point of
view
i think it's coming from a place where
i think she doesn't know
better
and
she's on her journey
of whatever it is and i feel sad that
yeah i i i pity her it's it's i i i
would i would hope that people would
find more
meaningful things in a relationship
beyond an an unrealistic number
at all because i just think that's an
excuse like you're 30 years old you
don't you don't know i don't pity you
she's a wrong woman
i can see that yeah that's the thing
like men men hit reality hard they're
rejected by that girl that's 16 in math
class she let's fall she lets the whole
class know but she turns you down
because she looks better if she could
turn down more guys
so
so reality hits men hard we're women
it's like
we choose to live in delusion
and it's a choice because clearly if
she's never had a boyfriend there's been
no takers i'm not saying that's my i'm
i'm not saying that i'm
relieving her for her own
like i'm not saying that she shouldn't
take responsibility for her life and her
choices and the way she presented
herself i i agree with you that
it's it's just my personal way of
reacting to things i understand i'm just
a very empathetic person so
i think i would want everyone to be on a
great place
i wouldn't want anyone to be
discriminated or
being treated poorly and that's why i'm
upset because
i i really feel for people who are
being
somehow told you're not good enough
because you can't get i'm sorry that's
right
and that's just that's just me i it's
not i'm not generalizing for everyone
that's just a personal thing and i feel
it's really sad that these people exist
this is where i think it's important um
see i'm not mad
i'll keep it 100 if you was a male
getting upset about that
i would have a different reaction to you
the fact that you're a female again i've
said that i can understand that and this
is why i also encourage men not to
be too emotional because
emotional men would
accept what she's asking for and end up
wifing her and you're just a snowball
effect you you you have a woman out
there asking for a million requirements
and if you're a man that feels sorry for
them type of women you start wife and
them type of women encouraging more
women to have a list of even more
requirements and then men start working
as well so it's important that i think
we understand the difference if you're a
female getting upset by that that's fine
if there's a man getting upset by that
that would almost encourage him to
accept what she's asking for
do you think if
you've said this before to bring back
bullying do you think if she was bullied
bruh it would solve so many problems
it would solve so no i'm serious i'm
serious none of y'all have been humble
you know what my brother told me i had a
big nose until i was 22
22. and you know what it humbled me
i don't know have a great night
thank you thank you
but but literally my brother my brother
from like the time i was a kid you'd
always tell me i was ugly and honestly i
feel like it can't kept me down to earth
no oh no it may be better yeah that
would be better yeah good and you know
what i was i was fat
i got on the treadmill you know what i
mean
it's your problem
that's what i'm saying i'm like if
someone was like that's how i say when i
watch it back i'm like i wish i was a
little bit more direct but i was in
shock i don't know if you saw my face i
was like
see it's you though you use that to
actually fuel yourself to do the right
thing instead of feeling sorry for
yourself yeah no that's what that's what
i think too i mean the problem with that
is um every person internalizes and
deals with trauma differently so it's
some people do it exactly the way you do
it so you you enter you actually make
into fuel and you make it useful the
problem is there are a lot of people who
don't and that's why we end up with a
situation where suicide happens because
people cannot get out of it and it
spirals out of control and i think
that's that's the thing like everyone's
an individual you will process your
trauma differently
um
i was bullied and it was horrible and
yes i understand that
the bully was bullied as well it was a
cycle she then felt that in order to
feel better about herself she's going to
bully her her own her own
people who are under her
and
and she was infamous for it and it was
it's so sad it got so many people
mentally and well work-related stress
people who had to go people just left
because they it was it wasn't well and i
have
i know there are people that i worked
with
who still cannot go back to that
workplace because if they're near it she
goes into a panic attack and i don't
think in general tough times build tough
people
that's what i think like i mean like
yeah some people
take process it differently but i just
think in general we're in
a place in society where no one can
handle criticism ever
and it's like any i mean how do you
think i deal with the comments all the
time like i have girls roasting every
part of my appearance right now on my
instagram i don't care yeah my brothers
did that for me the first time you're
the same people that preach posit uh
body positivity yeah it's the whales the
whales are coming the whales are coming
like i just think that tough times breed
tough people
it does um but i think again
that that depends on the personality
and
i personally have and i still deal with
mentally and well patients
and i can tell you it's it's very sad
at the the different stories they go to
the horrors they've lived through from
childhood and onwards
and
the honest truth is you cannot just tell
them to suck it up and deal with it
because it is trauma and
what do you have to do what else do you
do though
like like because because it's like it's
it's kind of like if you don't
like like what what are you supposed to
do i mean i understand like you go so
you talk about it so
can i ask the question so then like you
go through the trauma you talk about it
but then it's like
what now like the only the only thing
you can do is move forward
so it's about realizing so for example
the idea of triggering right i don't
understand what the whole idea of
trigger warning is i think as you say
it's like trying to cater to a certain
amount of people who can't deal with the
fact that they are triggered by
something
the important thing about being
triggered is that actually
whatever is triggering you is a
statement it's neutral and you are being
triggered because you
for some reason have some type of trauma
because of that
so
for example it's very personal but one
of the things i saw online a different
youtuber the guys were saying exactly
the same if you're a girl over if you've
if you are a girl who
have been single for a certain amount of
time that's a red flag
and the first time i heard that i was
triggered i was like oh my god like what
and and rather than react which a lot of
people do a lot of girls then they lash
out and they're horrible i say to myself
no no no why are you triggered
and i was like because he's he's saying
truth
because guess what when you meet someone
first impression is your innate alarm
system
you need that to try and
you know protect yourself it's part it's
natural to have an alarm now of course
it's important to then
when you get to know someone because you
can't always judge a book by their cover
so it's important to take the red flags
but don't run with it and take it beyond
and all and so i asked myself why on
earth are you triggered
because you shouldn't be it's a
statement and i said it's because
i've been single for a while and guess
what it's triggering me because i don't
want to i
i don't want to be single if you know
it's more and and this is the thing so i
realized hey so
well what are you going to do about it
well why don't you work on yourself why
don't you work on your femininity why
don't you work on making yourself the
best version you can so that maybe when
you and the right person come in then
you're at the right energy to be with
that person if you notice most people
are triggered by the truth like you said
so
if someone says something about it
that's not true that wouldn't trigger me
personally i don't figure if someone
says oh yeah this is that it's not true
i could say no it's not sure like if
someone called you short you wouldn't
care
but i don't know because like i always
think about when we talk about trauma
like what is trauma because all of you
all throughout all of human history
we're all involved in like war
starvations
and now it's like we talk about like
trauma being okay you were bullied a
little bit as a kid like i just feel
like our ancestors would look at us and
laugh it's because
because throughout all of human history
we had horrible lives
and nobody had to like
talk like go to a psychologist and talk
about it